yahoo finance reports that oreos have
glammed up their classic cookie with a
brand new
lady gaga oreo oh my god that's right
they've given it the full gaga makeover
with pink cookies and green cream and if
you're a little monster and a cookie
monster congratulations on this very
special day ross before we dig in
can i invite someone to this cookie
party uh please do okay cause he's
someone that i love so much and i'm so
excited he is a comedy phenomenon online
going viral for his hilarious laughter
larger than life impressions from
everyone from the kardashians to billy
eilish
ugh and a mac cosmetics girl one of my
favorites take a look at this
hi texting mama welcome to math oh yeah
i'm a global makeup artist so i have
this frosted firework collection bib how
gorgeous is that but i'm using the mac
422n46 brush of the infamous ruby woo
i took like 60 of these from the back
i'm just putting a little highlighter on
okay i am obsessed and he's really here
please welcome benito skinner aka
instagram's phenomenon benny drama hi
daddy
i'm so excited do you want to try the
lady gaga cookies with us you have this
i think it's time i have it all right i
just want to say that this is honestly
worth like a thousand dollars in weho
right
like these are sold out
i know yeah just when i get my body kind
of together lady gaga like has to make
this dream come true for me uh oreo omg
all right ready one two three got it
yeah uh uh-huh
oh it's good it tastes like just
immediately pause an oreo
it's delicious it's delicious i think
this should be a trend you know like
musicians coming up with um desserts
like madonna could have my doughnuts or
megan the stallion could have biscotti
biscotti audi audio
i was like where is this going yes yes
you're in okay um wow benito will you do
some news with us
i would love to oh yes
okay
so i came across this story because so
many people are dreaming about travel
right now and this next story is pretty
hard to resist cnn reports that you can
snap up an italian villa in the mountain
town of pikari
for one euro one euro yes now i'm sure
there is a billion caveats but unlike
any other recent italian villas you can
move into these fixer uppers right away
okay i've been playing this game with my
friends lately
um
if you could go anywhere
today or tomorrow where would you go
okay well i have to say that this story
is like my under the tuscan sun fantasy
you know i bought a villa in tuscany i
would italy would be on the list but i
have to say right now just because the
weather's so cold here puerto vallarta
would be on my list i mean a margarita
by the ocean hello ross wants to have
some fun in the sun benny benito what
about you where would you go
this is so hard honestly i haven't been
in new york for like a year and i just
really want to like go to a bar and have
like a bartender ignore me
like that sounds so good to me
but
like fantasy travel is a thing right now
right you look at the on your phone i've
been having all these zoom calls when we
you know work and i keep asking
everybody where would you go because i
just i keep dreaming of going somewhere
i've been so content and understanding i
need to just shelter in place i'm lucky
enough to have a job i get to go to
and so i haven't questioned it and
lately i'm like i i'm dreaming and
um you know if everyone is curious about
this italian villa situation go to our
website and you can check it out there
um and also
can you answer this poll with us where
would you go
and join us in this conversation because
i just feel like we're on the precipice
of just needing to dream and go and
maybe that very place is somewhere you
actually get to sometime in the near
future but where would it be okay this
next story oh yeah um that's yours ross
well it's it's elon musk and spacex will
send civilians to space by the end of
2021. hello the future is here it's a
mission commanded by tech entrepreneur
jared isaacman who donated a hundred
million dollars to saint jude's just for
the chance to go up in space and now
he's opening up the three other seats in
the capsule to civilians all right so i
gotta know drew benito would you ever go
up in space benny benito
um
i mean i've seen gravity i think that's
actually good that kind of sounds like
my version of hell but
to those who want to go i love that like
go off but yeah that actually would be
my nightmare like can you bring your
skin care like is there can you bring
coffee it's like three ounces i think
it's the same as when you're flying
yeah
ross would you go
i used to be afraid of heights and then
i went skydiving which i can't believe i
did and it sort of cured my fear of that
whole thing so i would go in a heartbeat
i would just want to go in first class
because do you
try to get i think you're going to be
strapped to a small seat for a long time
i have a joke though do you want to know
what kind of nuts they serve
uh in this first class what astro nuts
that took me a second but it's funny
i was like expecting way worse
um yeah i was like okay cable let's go i
know right no nuts nuts cheesy dad jokes
i'm with you actually and what
this story made me realize when we were
curating the news for the three of us to
discuss was that as much as i wanted to
dream of going somewhere else
that i was so happy here on planet earth
and i love life and i was actually
convinced and content that
um
i i'm happy here and so it was a really
good thing she took it deep benny yeah i
know i'm like okay i'm crying
you are here on earth benny benito
it's true i love all your impressions so
much you make the world a better place
you're so talented and i heard you made
a new video is this true
i did i made a little nod to ever after
um i had two it's one of my faves and
honestly it was on my halloween costume
shortlist
for a really long time i was like when
am i gonna be able to do it and i was
gonna do it this year but i was like we
can't really go outside so i'm gonna
like wait
and then this was my opportunity to
finally do the wings and do my like just
breathe moment and i did it i'm so
excited yeah and i think you're like
teasing it and you can go watch on the
website okay so everybody obviously
bennydrama7 and seven was like your
football jersey oh it's it's so
embarrassing so um when i got instagram
i was still in the closet so i thought
it would be fun to like just add a seven
at the end so um and the original like
benny drama will not give me that handle
so i'm penny drama seven for life i love
it lucky seven and yeah was that like a
football jersey thing or am i crazy
it was my number for football what
position were you just tough um i was
wide receiver i don't know
well go long
i was like wow i really set ross up for
that okay well guess what you're getting
wide reception now from the whole world
beautiful
okay i love that benny's brand new video
head to our website at
thedrewberrymoreshow.com
benito thank you for everything
this was heaven i love you both and i
feel so honored we love you too
[Music]